bonsoir gérard longuet le ministre de la
défense est l'invité ce soir de preuves
par 3 merci d'être avec nous leurs
longues et c'est un bon choix
le jour où pour la première fois un
sondage donne nicolas sarkozy en tête du
premier tour de la campagne
présidentielle alors vous nous direz ce
soir si on assiste à un tournant dans
cette campagne dont 15 minutes dominique
chabrol de notre partenaire la fp nous
rejoindra pour évoquer avec vous les
questions de défense et puis enfin en
fin d'émission michael de la messe de
public sénat sera avec nous sur ce
plateau pour évoquer avec vous une
espèce en voie de disparition à laquelle
vous appartenez les libéraux fin donc
pour commencer cette émission gérard
longuet ce donc ce sondage ifop fiducial
pour public cela paris match et europe 1
qui donne pour la première fois nicolas
sarkozy en tête du premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle devant
françois hollande parce que c'est un
essai villepinte
c'est l'effet d'une campagne dont
villepinte a été un moment fort de deux
observations d'ailleurs les meetings
aujourd'hui sont diffusés dans les
foyers grâce aux différentes chaînes de
télévision dans la ville
les chaînes d'information et ce ne sont
pas simplement les 50 60 mille
spectateurs de villepinte
ce sont les centaines les millions de
téléspectateurs qui voit en direct le
candidat s'exprimer et à villepinte le
candidat à donner une ligne directrice
qui était la france forte par une europe
forte et l'a7 est un événement important
parce que l'idée de la france forte en
soit personne ne peut être contre mais
comment est ce qu'il a défendu avec son
expérience d'ancien président de l'union
européenne son engagement européen c'est
à dire voilà il faut que la l'europe
soit au service de la protection des
européens et comme il vient d'obtenir un
bon accord sans les anglais il ya de la
crédibilité aux formes europe fermé une
heure
le faux pourrait de plus voilà en effet
se protéger des courants d'air inutile
et il y en a on parlait des sondages qui
se suivent et qui se contredisent
puisqu'elle en étant seulement un
nouveau sondage tns sofres donne
françois hollande toujours en tête du
premier tour à 30% devant nicolas
sarkozy à 26% nicolas sarkozy qui perd
deux points c'est donc loin d'être gagné
tout à fait je veux dire par là que les
sondages donnent des photos un moment
chacun avec sa méthode chacun avec son
échantillon il faut être d'une dune
d'une sérénité totale d'ailleurs les
gens qui votent
hollande je l'espère ne vote pas pour
des sondages et je soutiens nicolas
sarkozy
quel que soit le sondage quoi qu'il
arrive donc françois hollande a raison
aujourd'hui quand il dit qu'il ne faut
pas se laisser impressionner par rien il
faut être d'une grande sérénité avoir
des convictions fortes c'est le cas de
nicolas sarkozy au second tour en tout
cas nicolas sarkozy est toujours
largement battu pour l'instant ça montre
que c'est très intéressant le deuxième
tout pot pour deux raisons d'abord il y
a dans le jugement que les français ont
de leur président de la république une
part d'affectif considérable peut-être
nicolas sarkozy par sa présence
médiatique par son dynamisme son énergie
et ses comportements et quelqu'un qu'il
suscite des réactions plus importante
que d'autres personnages d'affection la
dimension est affectée ces dames on nous
a tellement aimé cher président en 2007
on aimerait vous retrouver je pense
qu'ils vont le retrouver telle qu'ils
l'ont aimé ce l'exercice de boire est
terrible et 7
il y a eu des tensions affective entre
le peuple et vincent inigo là je pense
qu'il peut par cette période de campagne
gomes et ans n'avait pas l'impression
que pour l'instant le second tour
ressemble plutôt à un référendum
anti-sarkozy
aujourd'hui n'est pas majoritaire au 2e
tour cet affectif et donc c'est
superficiel
je pense que la démarche de nicolas à la
foi de convictions et modestie
je n'avais pas toujours habitué c'est
important pour les français se disent il
a un mandat c'est constitutionnellement
et dernier mandat il a l'expérience on
verra les jugements entre les deux tours
ils n'auront rien à voir avec le premier
thème pourquoi je veux le dire très
simplement au premier tour on pense à ce
que l'on n'a pas aimé au deuxième tour
on pense à ce que l'on va pouvoir créer
construire avec le président que l'on
souhaite d'émargement des sticks avec
peut-être un petit peu trop tard non
dans sa poésie dans l'action de nicolas
sarkozy étaient dans l'action jusqu'au
bout et c'est simplement son engagement
qui laisse apparaître moi je le pratique
très directement sur le terrain de la
défense c'est quelqu'un en réalité de
deux traits humains et de très attentif
mais sa culture du résultat bouscule les
habitudes
en tout cas la droite annonce depuis des
semaines un effondrement possible du
candidat mais pour françois je n'ai
jamais cru je n'ai jamais cru parce que
il y en france une gauche qui existe qui
est tout à fait respectable il ya une
extrême gauche qui se maintient bien le
candidat écolo et tente assez faible
pouvoir dérisoire françois hollande fait
le plein de ce qui n'est pas l'extrême
gauche et donc il fait les 30% de ce qui
n'est pas l'extrême gauche c'est un
résultat tout à fait honorable c'est le
résultat de la gauche dans ce pays est
ce que vous pensez comme patrick buisson
le monsieur sondage de nicolas sarkozy
qui dit dans le monde daté de ce soir de
demain que le croisement des courbes va
obliger le candidat socialiste à prendre
plus de risques
oui il y a on y reviendra sur des thèmes
qui me sont plus familiers comme la
défense une absence de françois hollande
une absence de signature une absence
tout court sur les projets qui était
tout à fait acceptable lorsque seuls les
règlements de comptes affectif des cinq
dernières années comptait qui va devenir
insupportable quand on pense à l'avenir
si on n'aime pas à nicolas sarkozy pour
le passé on peut voter hollande
mais quand on pense à l'avenir on n'a
aucune raison de voter hollande mais
quand même des risques décisifs qui ont
marqué ce début de campagne je pense à
la proposition de françois hollande de
taxer à 75 % les revenus supérieurs à 1
million d'euros est ce que là il a
réussi un coup qui a quand même marqué
durablement ça ne prend pas l'air très
honnêtement personne ne se sent
concernés par ces cette taxation qui est
vraiment une ultra une infime minorité
de nos compatriotes
en revanche on se pose la question mais
pourquoi diable dit il cela à ce moment
si ce n'est pour lutter contre mélenchon
il ya une surenchère mélenchon aux
normes qui d'ailleurs bénéficié à
mélenchon qui gagne des points
et lorsque l'on dépassé dans un sondage
derrière c'est parce qu'il avait perdu
notamment profil mélenchon donc lorsque
hollande est à gauche
les gens disent mal ont carrément à
gauche avec mélenchon mais la réponse de
nicolas sarkozy est venu hier soir en
proposant de lier fiscalité et
nationalité ça c'est une bonne idée de
la part d'autres candidats je veux dire
c'est un sujet qui sera débattu au
parlement et dans la mise en oeuvre est
assez complexe
l'idée que l'on peut comprendre mais tu
veux dire tout à fait d'accord
bah de toute façon les lois sont votées
au parlement les l'idée que je que l'on
peut comprendre c'est que quelqu'un qui
doit sa fortune à son pays a des
obligations vis-à-vis de lui en même
temps on doit reconnaître que ceux qui
aujourd'hui sont riches
honnêtement on payait l'impôt sur le
revenu l'impôt sur les plus values
l'impôt sur les successions l'impôt sur
le capital dont déjà pas mal payés dans
la surenchère fiscale moi je pense qu'il
faudra tranquillement examiner ça ou par
le parlement c'est vous qui a utilisé le
mot de toute façon si les gens d'à côté
paye 75% ici on les poursuit en
californie ou bien alors l'amérique
latine pour qu'ils continuent de payer
bon c'est une voie là c'est une idée
donc le parlement débattra vous du
parlement devrait de renégocier toutes
les conventions fiscales c'est le
dimensionner les pays en transition
en revanche là où je soutiens du moulin
sarkozy c'est le fait que nos grandes
entreprises
alors certes elles réalisent leur
chiffre d'affaires et leurs bénéfices à
l'étranger mais 8% de fiscalité sur les
bénéfices quand les pme font 30 % il ya
un petit problème et nicolas sarkozy a
eu raison de poser marine le pen à ses
500 signatures depuis ce matin c'est une
bonne nouvelle pour la démocratie
française bonne nouvelle pour marine le
pen pour l'hémorragie française aussi
parce qu'il ya des gens qui votent front
national
qu'ils aient leur candidat moi je ne me
tairais conforter votre candidat au
premier tour jeu parfaitement ambigu je
suis incapable de vous le dire
dans sa conférence de presse en tout cas
cet après-midi marine le pen elle a
surtout steam mag stigmatiser la gauche
affairistes selon ses termes
est ce que ça veut dire qu'elle ménage
un peu lumineux l'ump est impossible à
venir elle rappelle que la gauche a des
relations avec l'argent que ses
relations avec l'argent sont connus et
cas c'est curieusement on en parlait peu
jusqu'à présent les magazines qui ont
souvent eu des couvertures extrêmement
cruelle pour nicolas sarkozy
gomes et difficulté aujourd'hui les
mêmes magazine on parle tant mieux les
français ont besoin d'être éclairés de
fûts de ce risque à travers un magazine
le fils de kadhafi dit que son père
aurait financé la campagne de nicolas
sarkozy en 2007 ça aussi c'est de la
calomnie
c'est parfaitement scandaleux c'est de
la calomnie à l'état brut
c'est en tous les cas l'affirmation très
très forte de l'équipe du candidat de
2007 jeu là confirme totalement pour
finir sur cette première partie gérard
longuet ce que vous avez envie de dire
qu'une seconde campagne pour un
président qui se représente c'est
forcément moins magique que la première
forcément forcément et en même temps
c'est c'est passionnant parce que on
renoue avec l'électorat et je pense
profondément que c'est la force de la
campagne de nicolas sarkozy qu
reviennent la réussite de l'université
reviennent la réussite de grenelle qui a
été c'est vrai compliquée par la crise
économique revient la réussite de la
réforme des retraites et on s'aperçoit
que ce revient le dialogue social
puisque les grèves ne paralysent plus le
pays et on s'aperçoit que le pays a
considérablement bouger et c'est en
effet plus difficile d'être sortant
parce que on est responsable de ce qui
va mal mais ceux qui vous soutiennent ce
10 mai après tout quel chemin parcouru
quels efforts faits qu'elle est fort
réussi mais ce qui fait pas un peu
campagne tout seul nicolas sarkozy vous
avez c'est un vrai sujet ça c'est un
vrai sujet et s'il ya mon avis je
l'évoquais tout à leur télévision et
internet
écrit compte - hors l'écrit le journal
presse écrite c'était l'occasion des
tribunes libres des expressions par
exemple vous avez raison je suis libéral
je suis modéré je suis girondin c'est à
dire décentralisateur et bien j'ai
vraiment j'aimerais dire des choses je
les écris et tu sais écrire est en
quelque sorte lettre morte parce que les
foyers le focus de la campagne sur le
candidat sur le candidat seulement mais
ce que vous vous sentez le résultat
aucun cas notre en tant qu'élu
suffisamment associés à la cantonade
vous avez dit l'autre jour je voudrais
qu'il quitte le jeu pour le nous font
oui alors ça c'est pour le et dont nous
c'était dans le et des mois il
s'adressait aux militants et pour la
france je crois que c'est les français
doivent s'aider les uns les autres dans
cette campagne les ministres ont du mal
à trouver leur place d'un côté nicolas
sarkozy vous mais un petit peu en
retrait et puis de l'autre parfois ils
vous reprochent aussi un soutien un peu
trop team et l'on regarde tout de suite
ce reportage de fabrice qu une écharde
ce dimanche ils étaient tous là une
première car si nicolas sarkozy regrette
un manque de soutien parfois c'est aussi
une volonté présidentielle
seulement neuf ministres sur 33 l'ont
par exemple accompagné lors de ses
précédents meetings
nous on est des bons soldats on est à sa
disposition
quand il a besoin de nous il sait nous
appeler il nous a associés à certains
angles réunion pas à d'autres de bruno
le maire à gérard longuet
la plupart des ministres sont cantonnées
à l'anonymat des réunions publiques ou
des petits meetings dans les allées de
villepinte on parle d'une équipe de
technocrates et de préfets autour du
candidat où seuls quelques poids lourds
du gouvernement seraient autorisés à
s'exprimer
les grands médias c'est moi j'ai en en
partie dirigé la campagne de 2007 qui
dealait déjà ça on dit déjà il ya la
séparation pour la rue d'enghien et
l'ump c'est la même chose là je crois
qu'en vrai le problème il n'est pas il
est pas là mais à la différence de 2007
la campagne connaît des ratés alors
certains ministres n'hésitent plus à
sortir de leur réserve
c'est vrai que les
le débat sur le halal n'est pas le plus
urgent pour la société française
d'aujourd'hui est donc bien besoin de
remise en cohérence du projet
présidentiel et du travail qui a été
fait depuis cinq ans et ça c'est le la
réunion
surprise à villepinte l'europe s'invite
à la tribune pas forcément du goût de
certains élus ump qui espéraient des
thèmes plus concret il ya des choses
qu'ils font il faut par exemple évoqué
maintenant par exemple tout ce qui se
passe sur les problèmes de du quotient
familial les problèmes de l'assurance
vie font des sujets qui concernent les
français à la violence et pas de
l'idéologie c'est pas des grandes
phrases mais c'est du concret est dans
une situation comme la nôtre on préfère
les gens congrès et les gens fument eu
officiellement pas encore de tension
entre l'équipe de campagne de nicolas
sarkozy et les élues ou ministres
seulement de l'incompréhension parfois
le meeting de villepinte doit donner un
nouvel élan à défaut de redistribuer les
rôles
voilà gérard longuet dominic savoie
notre confrère de la fp nous a rejoints
sur ce plateau pour vous interroger à la
suite de ça ce sujet monsieur longuet
bon jour pour rester quelques instants
sur l'organisation de la campagne vous
avez dit quelques jours que dans cette
campagne nicolas sarkozy est affaibli
par sa générosité
si j'ai bien compris ça voulait dire
qu'il essayait justement de trop en
faire de tout faire lui-même est ce que
vous lui le dit est ce que vous essayez
de le convaincre justement d'associer
les autres et est-ce qui vous écoute
il a demandé à chacun de ses amis et
j'en fais partie
le fait d'être ministre n'est pas un
label d'amitié mais je suis un ami je le
soutiens je le soutiens sur mes secteurs
de compétences là où j'ai de l'autorité
n'ai pas besoin de recevoir de lettre de
mission de d'un quartier de campagne où
je n'ai que deux d'excellents camarades
mais moi je sais ce que j'ai à faire ce
que je sais ce que j'ai à dire
j'ai devant moi un candidat qui parle de
sujets de défense je lui réponds je lui
réponds avec la compétence qui est la
mienne mais je ne suis pas candidat à la
présidence donc moins d'autorité
politique un peu de compétences quand
même est-ce que vous avez accès par
exemple au qg de campagne on dit qu'il
est trop fermé ce qg de campagne alors
demain nicolas sarkozy reçoit enfin les
parlementaires ump
non on y va quand on veut tous les
garçons les filles qui sont des plus
jeunes que moi mais je les connais bien
non non non ils ont exactement l'âge que
je l'avais lorsqu'avec françois léotard
on faisait de la politique et on
bouscule un peu les choses c'est
exactement le mot nage 40 ans c'est
parfait donc j'ai ministre puisque vous
êtes ministre au moins encore pour les
deux mois qui viennent
le titre a mis tout le monde dans notre
vie vous vous voyez beaucoup d'unités
vous les voyez tous les jours comment
vous les sentez la proche de l'élection
est ce que l'idée d'une alternance ci
doit y avoir une alternance est acquise
ou est ce qu'il y ait encore des
inquiétudes ne valent pas d'alternance
en revanche il ya deux sentiments
extrêmement fort chez les militaires une
fierté d'être reconnu par le pays ils
ont le sentiment aujourd'hui que l'hymne
la mission des militaires qui est
d'intervenir pour que la parole de la
france soit forte est une mission
reconnue et pour eux c'est une vraie
gratification deuxième sentiment c'est
l'inquiétude parce que l'armée ce sont
des moyens financiers considérables en
équipements et en fonctionnement et ils
se disent que toute alternance c'est le
risque d'une remise en cause de ce qui
fonctionne bien depuis cinq ans une loi
de programmation qui était en gros
respecter sur les défis du sujet
défendre justement il
suit un thème qu'on n'aborde pas trop si
celui du budget de la défense c'est 32
milliards millions c'est l'un des plus
gros budget de l'état dans un pays dans
une période d'économies forcées il va
falloir trouver de l'argent alors les
candidats en tout cas les principaux les
candidats qui ont des chances d'être au
second tour disent que le budget la
défense de ce ne sera pas une variable
d'ajustement
mais est-ce qu'il faut pas s'attendre à
des coupes dans le budget plus ou moins
sévères mais vous savez les expériences
parle d'elle-même depuis cinq ans
nicolas sarkozy en particulier au
printemps dernier où c'était difficile a
permis à la loi de programmation d'être
alimenté régulièrement en contrepartie
reconnaissons le
l'armée a fait un effort de productivité
considérable puisque nous avons diminué
de 54 milles nos effectifs de 2008 à
2015 et nous sommes sur la pente normal
de diminution dans les années jospin
l'armée a servi de variable d'ajustement
et les programmes d'équipement ont en
effet été suspendus et reportés les
militaires le savent ils ont cette
expérience
voilà ils sont un devoir de réserve mais
je vois bien où va la confiance sur le
simple plan des moyens matériels de
l'armée sur lesquels l'armée n'est pas
efficace j'ajoute le plan du
commandement c'est très important
ce que demandent des soldats c'est
d'être commandés
car on peut tout faire avec d une troupe
sauf ne pas la commande est clairement
et la force de nicolas sarkozy et de
l'avoir commandé clairement en libye
naturellement côte d'ivoire et en
afghanistan après avoir réfléchi
accompagner l'effort américain considéré
qu'aujourd'hui le territoire dont nous
avons la charge sont allés en mesure
d'être pris en charge par l'armée
nationale afghane et qu'il faut
organiser maintenant une transition
tranquille nous a dit que les liens de
confiance rétablie aujourd'hui entre la
wii le président république le début du
quinquennat le nazisme et aux ti-cats le
début avait été marquée par un incident
malheureux qui avait été un petit peu
exagéré parce que l'homme qui réactive
il réagi une fois qu'on est habitué ça
va on lui dise qu'on pense et ça se
terminera vers moi j'ai aucun problème
avec lui les militaires non plus
simplement il réagit et entre nous il a
raison parce que que l'on soit solidaire
de l'administration en général de la
mine et de l'armée en particulier
n'interdit pas d'avoir un regard
attentif sur la façon dont fonctionne
une administration ou une arme est un
des thèmes de campagne en matière de
défense dominique s'arrête l'afghanistan
organisée
c'est vraiment le dossier sur lequel il
est un vrai désaccord entre le
président-candidat nicolas sarkozy et
son principal challenger françois
hollande nicolas sarkozy s'est prononcé
pour le retrait des troupes françaises
fin 2013 françois hollande dit 2012 fin
et pour vous vous dites ça c'est un
mensonge ça c'est pas tenable
oui oui c'est un mensonge parce que
techniquement ce n'est pas les
militaires disent nous on fixe une date
et on fait ce qu'on a à faire avec les
moyens dont on dit c'est alors la raison
est très simple nous avons une mission
en kapissa qui est d'aider l'armée
afghane assumer seules la sécurité
cette mission nous sommes en train de la
réussir si l'on annonce aux talibans qui
sont nos adversaires de toute nature
différents groupes mais qui sont nos
adversaires action l'adversaire de
l'armée afghane sur leurs annonces
publiques n'en ont pas fin 2012
c'est à dire on se carapate parce que
c'est le terme exact il faut aller vite
compte tenu du matériel compte tenu des
sommes engagées compte tenu des des
places occupées il faut aller vite
brutalement on laisse tomber l'armée
afghane on lui dit débrouille
débrouillez vous tout seul et on donne
un signal fort aux talibans c'est le bon
moment d'attaquer à la fois une armée
afghane déstabiliser et des militaires
français exposés dans une manoeuvre qui
est toujours difficile qui est l'âme à
l'oeuvre du repli fût ce sur des
positions préparer avant donc je pense
que si françois hollande avait fait
l'effort de comprendre ce qui se passait
et s'ils avaient simplement qui m'a
demandé mon avis le dialogue républicain
et les parlementaires je suis ministre
je leur ai expliqué que nous
faisons nous pouvons envisager la
transition que nous avons obtenu pour la
kapissa mais qu'il faut faire les choses
dans l'ordre la discipline pour ne pas
exposer nos alliés avec tous les
militaires français qui sont tombés ils
sont emery pour que l'armée afghane
puisse faire le boulot qu'on savait très
bien qu'on n'allait pas rester 25 ans en
afghanistan mais on voulait former une
armée nous sommes en train de réussir ce
pari
on ne peut pas la laisser tomber ses pas
et s'il n'y a pas beaucoup d'un effet
d'annoncé quand même d'un côté comme de
l'autre on fixe une date en sachant
qu'après le retrait va prendre des mois
il faudra encore des mois pour rapatrier
le dans l'axé ryan n'est pas une affaire
franco française c'est une affaire
mondiale
il y à une presque à la coalition si à
choisir qu'un de lisbonne en novembre
2010 a fixé une date 2014
nous nous avons dit à nos partenaires de
l'otan 2014
ok mais il se trouve que dans la zone où
nous sommes responsables ça marche et
karzaï quand même patron local dit oui
ça marche donc nous pourrons transférer
vous avez des quatre jours de très très
important c'est plus que nous allions
c'est une tragédie
c'est une tueriie c'est une tragédie et
cela montre que le devoir de transition
c'est à dire laisser les afghans gérer
eux mêmes leurs problèmes est un devoir
absolu
nous devons les supp les soutenir pour
faciliter la transition
nous ne pouvons pas laisser
éternellement nos soldats
les notes sont solides parce qu'ils sont
aguerris entraîné personne est à l'abri
d'une tragédie de ce type
il se trouve que ce sont les américains
qui l'ont commis ce c'est très embêtant
pour je crois qu'ils en souffrent
vraiment qu'est ce que ça compromet
justement à court terme à la mission
américaine annonce à la compromet pas
mais ça accélère cette évidence ça
conforte cette évidence c'est que c'est
à l'armée afghane d'exercer l'autorité
et la sécurité dans son pays même s'il
doit y avoir un soutien aérien ou un
soutien en formation ou en logistique
peut-être une question d'actualité
immédiate la france a annoncé ce matin
le retrait de 400 de ces hommes de ces
soldats de là
finul au liban certains ça intervient à
un moment où il ya de très fortes
tensions dans la région notamment avec
la répression qui se poursuit en syrie
est ce que c'est le bon moment de
retirer des troupes
je veux dire ça fait 30 ans que la finul
et aliments vous le savez 1078
exactement ça fait plus de trente ans
qu'elle est 34 ans ex week-end et au au
liban et on peut se poser la question de
la pertinence de la mission aujourd'hui
nous avons estimé on avait 13 cents
hommes nous avons estimé qu'avec en
octobre 500 soldats de moins on restait
à 800 on pouvait rendre les services que
les nations unies attendent de nous mais
il n'était pas nécessaire de maintenir
des effectifs aussi important l'onu l'a
compris puisque c'est le plan de l'onu
que nous avons fait aussi des motifs
budgétaires la guerre et attendait oui
naturellement sillonné mon devoir de me
la défense c'est d'économiser l'argent
du contribuable
c'est pas de dépenser sans limite ce qui
est dur à gagner du temps dans les
propositions que françois hollande est
intervenue dimanche sur la défense dans
les propositions qu'il a faites sur le
sujet il ya notamment un contrôle accru
du parlement sur les opérations
extérieures des armées sur le budget de
la défense parlementaires expérimentés
comme vous doit être ce tissu de choses
différentes sur le contrôle par le
parlement du budget défense complètement
d'accord
d'ailleurs c'est ce que nous faisons sur
les opérations de remarques
la première c'est que la réforme
constitutionnelle voulue par nicolas
sarkozy adoptée en juillet 2008 a obligé
le gouvernement
au bout de quatre mois à soumettre
l'engagement des forces françaises
un vote du parlement ça n'existait pas
avant
tant que nous avons devancé la demande
de françois hollande sur le principe de
l'intervention
en revanche dans la conduite des
opérations je refuse au parlement le
droit de décider à la place d'un
capitaine commandant à compagnie ou un
lieutenant commandant une section 7 aux
militaires
conduire les opérations sur le terrain
dans la ligne que le ministre de la
défense leur demande de respecter sur la
proposition du président de la
république nous ne pouvons pas avoir une
armée parlementaire commandé par les
commissions des héros qu'une commission
française ni lui c'est nadine
l'assemblée le demande
elles veulent contrôler mais elles ne
sont là pas là pour diriger
dernière question concernant cette
thématique de la défense dominique oui
tout autre sujet mais qui n'est pas
moins un sérieux c'est vous avez eu vous
avez eu le privilège ou en tout cas vous
avez une manifestation devant vos
fenêtres
samedi une manifestation des pousses de
militaires ce qui est quand même que
très rares les épouses des militaires
qui protestaient contre les retards dans
le paiement de soldes à cause d'un
nouveau logiciel informatique qui est
mis en place au ministère
bon de tous les systèmes informatiques
ont eu du mal à se mettre en route mais
là ça fait quand même cinq mois que ça
dure comment est-ce qu'on en est arrivé
là
j'en veux beaucoup à françois hollande
d'avoir stigmatisé le travail des
militaires car c'est le travail des
militaires c'est pas le travail des
ministres fait mois-là l'amitié de
reconnaître que je ne suis pas derrière
mon ordinateur pour pour assurer les
paye
ça fait plusieurs années que
l'administration invente un logiciel
moderne il s'appelle louvois il
fonctionne pour le service d'e santé
depuis un an bien
il fonctionne pour l'administration
centrale bien là il m'arrive
j'aimais mire la marine a décidé de
passer à la fin du mois de mars deux
semaines où l'on voit pourquoi ça marche
pas l'armée de terre enfin ça marche pas
il ya un ennemi pour cent de difficulté
chaque mois certains sont payés trop
d'autres sont payés inégalement et
quelques amis et quelques uns parfois
oui ça représente aucun sens alors on
cherche et leur nom ce qui est grave
c'est pas ça représente 400 c'est que
chaque mois c'est pas tout à fait les
mêmes si on avait si on disait à chaque
bon ça diminue à chaque mois mais c'est
pas tout à fait les lois de la magie
mais il fallait mettre ce logiciel en
eux pourquoi parce qu'avant ça marchait
moins bien simplement le savais pas
ça marchait moins bien par exemple j'ai
appris comme ministre je suis un nouveau
ministre
les indemnités en campagne a été versée
tous les six mois
avec six mois de retard avec le logiciel
nous voit on va pouvoir améliorer cela
quand vous dites il ya une manifestation
oui c'est vrai il ya une manifestation
on reconnaît bien volontiers
il y avait plus de caméras que deux
manifestantes mais c'est normal
elles sont là pour s'exprimer l'une
c'est un peu compliqué parce qu'elle a
trop reçu donc c'est son problème c'est
que les autres ont été les familles ont
toutes été indemnisées dans la semaine
dans la semaine du paiement pour
personne n'est laissé sans ressource et
l'armée personne ne les saisons au
racing qui critiquaient le dialogue
social au sein des armées
est ce que le fait qu'ils aient eu
justement en bout de 2 au bout de cinq
mois a eu un rassemblement une
manifestation de grogne devant le
ministère c'est pas ça leur donne pas
raison le fait que le look sociale je
reconnais que nous avons engagé une
réforme forte de l'armée de réforme
administrative dans les formes
d'organisation une réforme des
procédures de fonctionnement et que dans
cette réforme il ya eu beaucoup
d'accompagnement
tout n'a pas été réussi et sur le voit
on va atteindre la perfection dans un
mois ou deux merci dominique gérard
longuet on va attaquer la troisième
partie de cette émission vous êtes donc
un des représentants de l'ailé libérale
de l'ump
un courant dont les idées n'ont plus
vraiment le vent en poupe alors dure
dure époque pour vous regardez ce
reportage de tran huy gérard longuet
appartient à une espèce en voie de
disparition au gouvernement celle des
libéraux c'est qu'elle est bien loin à
la belle époque de démocratie libérale
aujourd'hui dilué dans l'ump les
libéraux doivent s'accommoder d'une
politique qui n'est pas toujours en
accord avec leurs idées exemple avec
hervé novelli secrétaire général adjoint
de l'ump et président des réformateurs
libéraux face à la misère ou à des
restructurations d'entreprises ou à des
fermetures d'entreprises
on peut avoir la tentation de dire il
faut fermer les frontières par exemple
où il faut augmenter nos droits de
douane
tout cela ce sont des mesures qui sont
des mesures
que nous combattons mais justement
fermer les frontières les droits de
douane c'est ainsi qu'a été compris le
discours de nicolas sarkozy sur schengen
ça n'est pas comme cela que je l' ai
compris les libéraux marche sur des
oeufs prône la régulation en temps de
crise et surtout défendre coûte que
coûte leur champion dont la course à la
présidentielle même s'il propose des
mesures protectionnistes
pour cet économiste les vrais libéraux
n'existe tout simplement pas en france
nous avons dans une certaine mesure des
socialistes de gauche et socialistes de
droite en france on n'a jamais essayé
sur libérale des hommes politiques sont
très sensibles à l'opinion et dans la
mesure où indéfiniment on répète les
mêmes thèmes antilibéraux par exemple à
propos de la crise est bien les hommes
politiques même si au fond d'eux-mêmes
aimerait exprimer des idées libérales et
bien ils sont en pêche parce qu'ils
estiment que c'est pas un vandale pour
point de vue électoral alors le
libéralisme est il particulièrement
impopulaire en france c'est l'avis du
politologue dominique reynié
c'est dès que l'on parle le libéralisme
économique qui lie à un malaise
et c'est sans doute lié au fait que nous
avons une culture politique qui est
depuis très longtemps surdéterminé par
la figure de l'état on voit
régulièrement que la france la france 1
et le pays dans le monde qui exprime la
plus grande réticence à l'égard du
marché du libéralisme de ces valeurs qui
aujourd'hui domine le monde alors
l'antilibéralisme hexagonal est-il
archaïques ou précurseur dans ce dernier
cas les libéraux français risquerait
bien l'extinction définitive à leur
extinction définitive ou non avec
d'abord monsieur midi je voudrais vous
parler peut-être du discours de villepin
de dimanche dernier discours de nicolas
sarkozy fermer les frontières couper
court aux accords européens de schengen
c'est pas vraiment le succès pour les
idées libérales que vous défendez alors
d'abord je n'ai jamais appartenu à
démocratie libérale je connais depuis
toujours
ne lésinons pas j'ai appartenu au parti
républicain et à l'udf
les mots ont leur sens parce que le
parti républicain c'était un parti de
convictions libérales mais qui passait
là l'idée républicaine comme une idée
fédératrice
il y as j'ai regardé le reportage
notamment pascal salin que j'adore par
ailleurs et que je lis avec plaisir mais
c'est un individualiste
la politique c'est une action collective
et si j'ai appartenu au parti
républicain c'était bien parce que la
république se fortifie d'une approche
libérale de la société donc là mais nous
avons à gérer la république et nous
n'avons pas à gérer des idées nous avons
à gérer une collectivité c'est pas tout
à fait là lorsque je suis dans le temps
je suis libéral je ne suis pas un
idéologue article article 2 on revient
sur ce que vous dites sur l'europe
je pense en effet que dans la
construction européenne nicolas sarkozy
a à en introduire un bouleversement
positif fantastique il a réintroduit sur
un sujet majeur
la règle de la majorité qualifiée
l'europe ce qui me paraît le plus
important de l'action de nicolas sarkozy
c'est le plan de le plan de
stabilisation l'accord économique sur la
la gestion budgétaire commune que les
anglais n'ont pas adopté ce qui est bon
signe que les tchèques je crois non pas
reconnu comme ça c'est leur problème
mais entre nombres européen est
notamment membre de l'euro désormais
nous acceptons la règle majoritaire
pourquoi je parle de cela parce que tout
le reste et notamment ce qu'a dit
nicolas sarkozy est important mais sera
soumis à la règle majoritaire
ou bien nous parvenons à convaincre des
partenaires sur schengen ou savait que
la situation de schengen est tout à fait
différente parce que c'est un accord à
option l'angleterre mans n'a jamais fait
partie
l'option schengen c'est un plus ce n'est
pas au coeur de l'europe ce qui est au
coeur de l'europe c'est une monnaie
commune qui va désormais s'adosser sur
une politique budgétaire commune soumise
à des règles de majorité qualifiée et
obligeant les états à respecter c'est ce
que dit nicolas sarkozy c'est pas la
fermeture des frontières il demande la
réciprocité
il se trouve que j'étais le ministre du
commerce extérieur non pas tout à fait
le ministre du commerce extérieur qui a
signé les accords de l omc à marrakech
en 94 dont je connais convenablement le
sujet et je vous dis une chose très
simple chaque grande zone régionale
s'organisent pour étaler les difficultés
pour passer des crêtes pour passer des
caps
il se trouve que l'europe souvent ne le
fait pas pourquoi ce que font les états
unis ou la chine
l'europe ne le ferai pas pour passerune
état et cela et meillon un projet
d'acheter européen cela est en effet
soumis à une règle de majorité c'est aux
français de convaincre leurs partenaires
de la majorité est ce que c'était mieux
pour vous sur le fait de vous avez
entendu ça dimanche vous avez dû bondir
souvent trop cher non d'abord parce que
je suis très calme
ensuite parce que oui c'est
nécessairement conjoncturel parce que
l'intérêt d'un pays et l'intérêt d'un
espace comme l'europe c'est de pratiquer
les changes et le libre échange à
condition de la crise lorsqu il y a
lorsque vous avez une déloyauté dans les
prix une déloyauté dont les monnaies une
déloyauté dans l'est les qualités et les
normes
vous êtes obligés de réagir un grand
pays libéral comme les etats unis c'est
réagir ses protégés à tel ou tel moment
son intérêt lorsqu'il est confronté à
des partenaires qui ne respecte pas des
règles identiques improvise un petit peu
sur la campagne française voulait dire
en revanche là où je suis d'accord avec
vous et de vous poser question
là où je suis un peu je n'ai pas je
considère que les corps intermédiaires
sont une chance pour notre pays
d'accord avec le président qui lient à
ces candidats il y à une dialectique du
point de vue de nicolas sarkozy entre le
président et le peuple mais pour avoir
été président de région pour être un élu
local de longue date pour voir le
travail fait sur le terrain par les
organisations professionnelles
syndicales je considère que les corps
intermédiaires sont des relais ne sont
pas des adversaires de la réforme mais
doivent être des toitures au nerf de la
réforme et référendum c'était une erreur
je le pense profondément sur les
thématiques
c'est une soupape de sûreté si un débat
national est bloqué mais je suis un d un
je suis un libéral parlementaire je suis
pour la démocratie parlementaire
j'étais sénateur j'ai été député je
pense que le débat parlementaire
enrichit le travail
le recours au référendum c'est lorsque
tout se bloque
or il ya beaucoup de sujets quand vous
vous posez un référendum sur
l'immigration par exemple c'est une
erreur aussi ce n'est pas un art et
leurs auteurs bloqués là encore si il ya
des blocages vous savez j'ai des gens
vont raconter quelque chose d'assez
drôle l'autre jour j'étais dans une
réunion politique et quelqu'un m'a dit
quelque chose que j'ai trouvé assez
juste il m'a dit voilà comprenait au 19e
siècle le peuple s'est battu pour que la
presse ne soit plus censurer et
aujourd'hui au 21ème siècle c'est là la
presse qui sont sur le peuple
nous avons un certain nombre d'idées
nous n'arrivons pas à les faire entendre
et en effet le référendum que marc fois
envie de rien et forcément les idées que
vous partez ça notamment oui mais mais
si vous voulez la question de la
pétition est posée par toutes sortes de
points de vue sur le sur l'écologie
c'est formidable il ya des tas de
contraintes qui apparaissent tous les
matins il ya un jour les gens le
pensaient monde m'attendait
avant de nous coller des contraintes
laissez nous respirer
bon je pense que nous les du référendum
comme je dirais soupape de sûreté pour
que le dialogue soit possible et que la
langue de bois prennent fin et une bonne
idée on attendait tout à leur club mais
soupape de sûreté
on entendait tout à l'heure claude
goasguen dans un des sujets qu'on est
différent ces démissions dire qu'il
souhaitait des thèmes de campagne plus
concret c'est peut-être le cas aussi de
plusieurs français est-ce que c'est
aussi votre sentiment
c'est alors ça c'est le problème de
l'exercice du discours d'une heure en
une heure vous mettez une ligne forte là
c'était à la suite de ce discours le
candidat est allé à l'essentiel les
anciennes c'est une france dans une
europe qui s'organisent en revanche on
peut le décliner et en effet le quotient
familial c'est un vrai sujet une france
forte c'est une france qui a des enfants
et la politique familiale française est
un succès et ce succès repose sur l'idée
de l'égalité entre les familles qui ont
des enfants et celles qui n'en ont pas
en termes de coûts sociaux de vie en
termes de niveau de vie le quotient
familial ne redistribue pas l'argent
entre les gros et les petits ils
redistribuent l'argent entre les
familles nombreuses et celles qui n'ont
pas cette solution du prolonge la
question perrine finalement de
travailler plus pour gagner plus lourde
avait compris ce que ça voulait dire en
2007 aujourd'hui quand on parle de la
france forte de l'europe à ce que les
gens comprennent réellement alors le
trophée c'est du concret c'est un c'est
une bonne question je pense que la vie
quotidienne il fait c'est le devoir du
président et celle de voir de nous qui
le soutenons la vie quotidienne de notre
pays est très largement déterminée par
son engagement européen prenait le
problème de la monnaie vous connaissez
mieux que quiconque
nous avons une monnaie qui est solide
qui est forte et qui est jugé par
certains trop forte par d'autres
satisfaisant et les trop fortes quand on
veut vendre et les satisfaisante quand
on achète du pétrole à l'étranger pour
que le pétrole soit le moins cher
possible à la pompe
l'europe est donc notre vérité de tous
les jours et un candidat à la
présidentielle qui s'exonèrent ray de
cette réalité européenne serait un
menteur parce que on ne peut pas
s'exonérer du fait que nous avons une
monnaie commune que nous avons des
échanges d'abord et avant tout avec nos
voisins immédiats et que nous avons
accepté depuis longtemps que nos lois
soient en harmonie avec les directives
européennes donc parler de l'europe et
dire simplement je vais porter mon
énergie à faire en sorte que l'europe
nous protège
c'est une attitude qui est
de bon sens vous connaissez bien nicolas
sarkozy puisque vous avez participé en
2007 à la campagne mais 80 mais en plus
en 2007
vous l'avez vous avez participé qu à la
campagne en 2007 c'était j'ai changé en
2012 il l'a dit plusieurs fois ce
dimanche
j'ai appris lequel de ces deux nicolas
sarkozy aujourd'hui vous séduit le plus
j'ai appris j'ai appris à l'épreuve des
responsabilités je trouve qu'il ya de sa
part une très grande sincérité à dire on
est élu c'est la joie l'allégresse
l'entousiasme tout est possible et puis
la la la la rafale de difficultés des
preuves de choc de deux tragédies font
que le président qui est en charge de
l'essentiel et vers l'est vers lequel se
tournent tous nos compatriotes et en
particulier avec le quinquennat
cette charge cette épreuve personnelle
est extraordinairement lourdes je
voudrais juste vous dire une chose
lorsque nous avons dans son bureau et
sous son autorité avec alain juppé
françois fillon décidé d'intervenir par
exemple en côte d'ivoire pour contrôler
monsieur gbagbo
je veux dire c'est une responsabilité
qui est puis un homme pour plusieurs
mois et il en a tous les jours des
responsabilités j'ai appris mais quand
françois hollande dit un quinquennat
n'est pas un stage d'apprentissage que
ce couple c'est d'une bêtise absolue
parce que mais c'est vrai que l'homme
n'a jamais rien a pris puisqu'il n'a
jamais rien exercé comme responsabilité
le wall street journal publie dans son
édition d'aujourd'hui un édito choc
intitulé nicolas le pen a le wall street
journal dénonce en fait une diversion du
candidat sarkozy sur l'immigration pour
ne pas affronter l'anxiété des français
est ce qu'il est si cynique que ça
nicolas sarkozy non mais nicolas est un
candidat du peuple
c'est vrai que je suis plus
conservateurs qu'il l'est et je suis
plus modérée vous aujourd'hui quand même
sur des positions batteur de toute façon
il y en a 2 au 2e tour et tu sais pas
j'ai pas le choix c'est que la france un
choix d'un président qui qui conduit
notre pays dans la réalité européenne
avec sa personnalité j'accepte la
personnalité parce qu'il conduit notre
pays dans la réalité européenne est en
effet ce que je suis en recherche ça les
anglo saxons aux ados
la provocation et vis-à-vis des français
ils multiplient en général se fendent
les formules assassines
il ne faut pas s'en faire ce sont nos
meilleurs alliés hills et nous sommes
leurs mails sur la campagne jean longuet
jean louis borloo doit-il apporter un
soutien franc et massif à nicolas
sarkozy je souhaite profondément parce
que j'entends jean loup est quelqu'un
qui a de l'imagination de la générosité
est toujours pas d'accord je suis pas en
accord avec lui c'était fait en 2007 il
nous a déjà fait en 2007
non non il a une valeur ajoutée à tracer
les centristes et les radicaux à
l'assemblée nationale ont décidé de
créer un groupe si jamais il arriva à
pouvoir avoir plus de quinze députés
est-ce que vous même les libéraux
si jamais la droite perd les élections
en 2012 vous allez devoir créer un parti
était un groupe parlementaire il ya quel
lagat que nous gagnons que nous perdions
la présidentielle est une réalité simple
c'est qu'au soir de l'élection
présidentielle la vie politique va
repartir
et nous savons une chose c'est que
nicolas sarkozy et lui fera un dernier
mandat
donc la question de la présidentielle
sera immédiatement le posez moi ce que
je souhaite profondément c'est que l'ump
reste un parti d'idées intérieur que
l'ump redevienne plus profondes et dont
un particulier sans courant et donnant
plus d'existence au courant différent
c'est l'enjeu c'est statutaire mais
c'est statutaire pour l'instant on a
gommé ses statuts parce que le président
de la république et les statuts le
prévoient chaperonne l'ump à partir du
moment où la question sera posée ce sera
un dernier mandat de l'avenir il faut
que l'ump soit vivante à partir du seul
combat qui vaille le combat des idées
moi tout ça dépendra bien sûr du
résultat du deuxième tour de la
présidentielle merci monsieur la même
chose oui puisqu'il n'y aura pas trois
mandats merci beaucoup gérard longuet
d'avoir été ce soir l'invité de
transporter merci michael merci à vous
de nous avoir suivis très bonne soirée
sur public sénat
présidentielle 2012
public sénat décline la campagne en
route vers la présidentielle
l'interview bonjour à tous bonjour j
non poursuivre notre route à la
rencontre des français comment votre
anti en 2012 on se retrouve très bientôt
dans un nouveau département et d'ici là
prenez partie sans a priori
reportage entretien nous allons répondre
à vos questions vous avez tous les
éléments votre possession vous de faire
votre choix à public sénat nous avons
choisi le débat d idées le débat de fond
pour essayer de vous le donner un point
de vue tous les quinze jours je vous
propose de prendre le pouls des débats
qui agitent la planète web et de décoder
les stratégies des candidats sur le net
et d'effectivement vous oublie pas
animés comme on aura pu le constater
la présidentielle c'est sur public sénat
l'ordre du jour ap les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
je suggère que nous et 15 europe de
l'est 900 soyez cas mais c'est une
aberration
merci monsieur bruit dans mesdames et
messieurs
mon nom est jack ralite
j'habite à aubervilliers dans l'unicité
il lui trouve bien je me souviens quand
je suis arrivé j'avais trois choses dans
ma musette et que je n'ai pas abandonné
pour nourrir mes interventions les
combats auxquels j'ai participé avec mes
collègues
la première c'est que j'étais maire
d'aubervilliers et que c'est une ville
qui ne vous laisse pas indifférent elle
vous marque pour toujours c'est une
ville populaire brud mettant brrr ça
c'est la première chose la deuxième bon
j'avais été ministre c'est une
expérience la santé le travail mais je
pense surtout à la santé on pénètre dans
des milieux qu'on ne connaît pas
résultats à prendre les combats mieux et
puis la troisième chose il ya un appel
qui avait été signé par 174
intellectuels et artistes pour que je
sois sénateurs sénat c'est sûr s'il a
semblé intéressant parce que je trouve
qu'on a plus le temps de travail est il
précisément quand j'étais ministre
j'ai aperçu qu'on aller plus en
profondeur
oui la greffe parle dans la rue devenu
nouvel espace public
la greffe parle comme une insurrection
mentale d'humanité la greffe parle et
récuse les solutions régressive libéral
et étatiste la greffe parle elle et le
peuple dans sa dignité sa diversité sa
responsabilité
la greffe parle pose des questions
humaines plus profonde encore que les
revendications déclaré et réclament tout
simplement la vie
c'était en plein en pleine grande
tourmente
et quand je vois ce que j'utilisais il
ya une vraie hier qu'il l'ait vraiment
condensé quand elle a dit au gré d'une
interview d'un journaliste tant que
l'argent dominera le monde
ils nous ont manqueront et je crois que
c'est ça la grande question
elle existe c'est ce jour-là elle
continue d'exister et dans une ampleur
bien plus grande actuellement mais
malheureusement et j'espère
provisoirement c'est l'argent qui dirige
l'argent caché et l'argent visible et
ils n'ont aucune commisération aucune
balle en jeu c'était 2 comme monsieur
juppé est bien rentré son projet
destructeur quoi et ils vont la gagner
enfin prévisions parce que je me mets
dans ceux qui se battaient mais ils ont
gagné ce qui fait que c'est toujours
possible
c'est complexe mais c'est toujours
nous devions débattre des profonds
problèmes de banlieue
après le conseil des ministres
exceptionnel de lundi ce débat a été
remplacé par l'examen d'une loi
d'exception ultra sécuritaire qui vise
en chesnais toute espèce de liberté
en exagérant toute espèce de danger ce
n'est pas l'ordre dans la république
c'est la république de l'ordre nous
sommes contre votre loi vous ne déclarez
pas la guerre à la pauvreté mais aux
pauvres la banlieue mérite tout autre
chose
excusez moi il y avait sarkozy en face
il était ministre de l'intérieur il
écoutait mai et appelle les parties
donc je n'ai pas eu de réponse venu lui
mais il était là et il était là après
avoir fait sa visite de la courneuve et
avoir parlé du karcher et il était là
pas avoir fait sa visite à argenteuil et
avoir parlé des racailles ou autre
vocabulaire
c'est symptomatique quand la réaction
veut taper l insulte le peuple dans sa
diversité et ont dit les gens ont dit
d'iberville une ville moche que les
légendes paris qui viendrait pas en
voiture à aubervilliers en étant
convaincu convaincus que leur voiture
disparaîtrait pendant le repas de
famille quand on arrive à mettre dans la
tête des gens de telles aberrations et
quand on injurie ainsi une population
populaire vraiment la réplique de cette
forte et je sais que là je les fais de
vente et ça m'a touché de l'écouter à
nouveau quand les propositions de
l'adversaire sont polis on peut discuter
se battre poliment mais quand les
discussions ne sont plus possibles et
qu'on se fait insulter et à un moment
donné où le malaise est si grand qu'il
ya des explosions qui se produisent je
pense que c'est une potentialités qui
existent dans ce pays est vraiment ce
débat là est un débat de la dignité
contre l'indignité